are you frustrated i'm so frustrated are
you kidding me
um i mean today it's like all sinking in
like oh my gosh like i don't even feel
like my personality even got a chance to
come out to be honest
by a vote of 13 to 0
kisha you are evicted from the big
brother house
did you think you would be the first to
go absolutely not
i'm like so disappointed that i'm the
first one
out of all stars i mean you waited so
long
more than a decade the fans were crying
for you to be
on this show again so how disappointing
is it
oh that makes me so sad when i hear that
it's very disappointing i feel like i
didn't even really get a chance to play
the house was so calm nobody was doing
anything like it was so different from
my season
so different what do you think your
downfall was was it that
was it not being able to adjust to this
strange
way no i just think my biggest downfall
was i didn't know
a lot of the houseguests so not knowing
cody
was a huge huge downfall for me
i feel like they all had a connection
they all knew each other
so he had nothing really to go off of so
i think he just kind of picked two
people that like
he didn't really know much about well
are you frustrated
i'm so frustrated are you kidding me i
mean today it's like all sinking in
like oh my gosh you know
like i don't even feel like my
personality even got a chance to come
out to be honest
and it was completely different like how
do you go around the house and navigate
to people that are just telling you that
they love you i love you i like you so
much i want you in here
there's nothing negative to say about
that you know it's
it's so hard nobody's acting crazy
nobody's throwing a fit
like i mean i'm up against like one of
the nicest people in the whole house
so it was a much different game you were
just blindsided by that
lack of emotion it sounds like
definitely i was waiting for
something to happen you know like
someone to say
something to give me you know some
reasoning
but even cody was like i love you like i
have nothing against you
you know this isn't personal and i'm
like okay
i understand like there wasn't much to
say to him to be honest
at that point well you got emotional
when you left i mean watching
you put the mask on while crying and
everyone was around you
what was that moment like i mean they're
whispering in my ear
i love you i love you as i'm walking out
the door
so i mean the minute someone like
hugs me i'm like it's done like i'm
it it was so oh i couldn't believe i was
crying again
i felt like you know so much in the
first week again i'm like are you
kidding me did it take you back to
crying all those years ago
absolutely absolutely which time was
worse
oh that's hard to say i walked in the
door
and obviously i got hit right away with
going up on the block and so i'm still
trying to adjust
to being in the house and i have like i
feel like i just have no time at all
to adjust to anything so it was just so
many emotions so many and then people
were telling you like i like you so much
i love you
like oh my gosh you're so sweet you're
so good you're so that
nobody's saying like why they would
possibly want me out of the house
i feel some energy around me and so
that being said like i do wish most of
you
the best of luck well you did say in
your speech that you wished
most people the best of luck uh so
who do you not wish the best of luck to
and who do you feel betrayed by
the most if anyone i'm not sure who is
the person that threw kevin's name out
there
i'm not i have my suspicions i'm kind of
thinking
that it was like david or tyler or
maybe even cody you know i just kind of
met
that to whoever is the one that like
initiated
the house to go kevin's way i think
people
feel like memphis betrayed you and this
would be the second time
so how does this betrayal feel this time
i'm not sure he betrayed me but again i
haven't
watched so i could be completely wrong
about this
you know he promised me that he would
give me his vote he promised me
that you know he had my back you know i
know
we all know that i can't trust memphis
100 i was hoping
if it came down to it that you know if
he needed to be like my last vote or
something i was hoping that he would be
there for me
but as far as like at the end of the day
you know these people had to stay in
they had to continue
to play the game and nobody wanted to
divide the house
right now so i completely understood
that they all voted one way
are there hurt feelings there a little
bit
yeah absolutely a little bit i would say
so what was your reaction when you saw
he won hoh
and what do you think he'll do with it i
wasn't aware that he won hoh
[Laughter]
wow wow
okay yeah that's interesting
now that i know uh-huh he's gonna go
after
um definitely a girl maybe even the
nicole's
because everybody likes them i think
janelle's safe
i think we all had a bond at the
beginning of the game so i think she's
gonna be okay
but any of the other ladies in the house
i don't
i don't i wouldn't consider them safe
thinking back on your
your week is there anything that you
wish you would have done differently
absolutely absolutely without a doubt um
i wish i would have went to cody the
first night
i wish i would have introduced myself to
him i wish i would have had a
conversation with him
i think that's like the main mistake
that i made
besides that you know again i haven't
seen it but i'm just
assuming that he kind of persuaded the
house on which way to go
there was a moment when it was up in the
air as to whether you knew who everybody
was
uh have you finally learned everyone in
the house's names
and do you wish you'd done more studying
you know the whole process happened for
me
super quick i did not get the time like
other house guests did
i mean when i say super quick i mean
very fast
there was no time to really do much
studying
i tried i really did i tried to go
through like
all the past episodes i tried to like
really get in there and know who people
were
yeah i'm a little embarrassed that like
you know there are a couple people that
i knew
nothing about yeah that definitely hurt
me
for sure would you play the game again
if you could
i absolutely would play the game again i
feel like i didn't even get to play this
time
what do you feel like people didn't get
to see me
like the real me like i feel like
everything was happening so quick
that like i was still in my shock zone i
was like
still coming out of being like wow i'm
in the big brother house and like wow
i'm in here with all these people and
just the adjustment of it so getting
like put up on the block
so fast like really through my whole
game
and then i'm like okay obviously i can't
go around here
and do too much because this cast is
very what people don't understand is
they're so chill and everyone was
you know this is the thing that i keep
trying to like play over my head they
were just like
i love you i love you so much like i
like you i want you in the house
like what do you say to that and then
i'm up against kevin
who is also a very nice person and
there's not a lot of negativity that i
can say about kevin he's not interacting
crazy
he's you know he's laying low honestly
he was moping most of the time
so i'm like this poor guy like what am i
gonna say against him and i didn't want
to bash him well who are you rooting for
and who do you hope follows you out the
door next
okay so i'm definitely rooting for
janelle or devon
or caser i love casey tell me why you
know i think caser is an amazing person
um just getting to know him and getting
to spend a little bit of time with him
he was always the one that was honest
with me he was so honest with me he
would tell me things that
nobody else was gonna tell me i think
there's a few times that he like
cornered me and was like listen
like they're gonna get you like when
everybody else is just creep
creeping around you know tiptoeing
around that's anything
who do you want to see follow you out
the door next
i would say probably um
cody why because i think he needs his
turn
he needs to sweat it out a little bit